would you say to people that maybe don't  get why maybe jokic got the MVP over  someone like indeed what makes yogic so  special besides the numbers the amount  of possessions and games throughout the  seasons throughout two years of him  winning MVP is it's crazy if you  actually go and watch the games he's got  a guy on them  the defender coming from here sometimes  Defender coming from here he's able to  look this way and throw a pass and he's  got three guys on like it's not easy  it's not just because he's passing the  ball or he's not doing too much work  like he's creating everything for us  literally everything so to watch him do  that possession after possession the  playoffs like it's it was pretty  incredible and they have the consistency  to do it is another thing I don't think  anybody else should have won it over  over I really don't